mi chiamo all'inizio ho 15 anni vivo a
l'aquila dove frequento il liceo
classico moltissime passioni tra cui la
danza e la musica ma anche un grande
interesse verso la medicina sin da
piccolo sono sempre stata spinta verso
il mondo della medicina e quello
scientifico e la presenza di mia sorella
ha fatto sì che questa passione si sia
sempre più ingrandita fino a ricevere un
pensiero analitico quasi illuminista
virginia è una ragazza di 22 anni alta
magra slanciata esile quasi sempre si
mostra solare e sorridente anche se
delle volte egoista ma in fondo di buon
animo ha una particolarità che in pochi
in tutto il mondo hanno autistica cosa
vi immaginate sia l'autismo la parola
autismo deriva dal greco auto e sta a
significare se stesso
questo può indurre chiunque a pensare
che siano degli esseri delle persone
apatici e insensibili e che raramente
comprendono il loro io tanto da
dimenticarsi appunto quella altrui ma
non sempre così possiamo definirlo un
disturbo della personalità che ha
moltissime sfumature come ad esempio il
disturbo nella sfera del parlato oppure
la mostra sa bravura in matematica o
altre materie essere olistico non vuol
dire essere affetto da chissà quale
morbo no assolutamente
per esempio a mia sorella è stato
diagnosticato a cinque anni dopo
tantissime visite alcuni utili altre
inutili virginio dio nonostante i
parecchi anni che ci separano ci
vogliamo moltissimo bene e per lei sono
sempre stata quel tipo di sorella che ad
ogni minima critica per auto diretta ha
sempre saputo rispondere difetto più che
altro perché sentire quel genere gli
sguardi
gli sguardi e comunque di parole faceva
più male a me che non a lei mi dava
infinito fastidio il fatto che venisse
preso in giro senza un apparente motivo
e per questo diventavo molto curiosa ma
solo ora capisco che un motivo per
restare attoniti di fronte ad alcuni
comportamenti di mia sorella
c'era e capisco anche che ospiti ho
sempre visti senza una giusta causa
senza un giusto motivo perché quello che
loro criticavano quello che loro
biasimava no era quello che per me
risultava perfettamente normale quindi
la mia quotidianità la mia quotidianità
non credo possa avere lo stesso
significato della vera parola poiché di
ripetitivo diciamo nei miei giorni non
c'è quasi niente reggina è come una
variabile e matematica noi dipendiamo da
lei e lei dipende da noi
nonostante tutto il nostro rapporto è
come un normalissimo rapporto tra
fratelli e sorelle pieno di odio e tavo
di risate e scherzi litigate e anche
pianti certamente non è semplice ma alla
nostra famiglia piacciono le sfide e
anche quelle difficili
con il tempo però ho imparato a
comprendere ogni sua sfumatura ogni sua
smorfia risata raramente anche qualche
parola e questo ha fatto sì credo che si
sia creato un giusto equilibrio che ci
permette di comprenderci e di vivere
serenamente per me ormai è diventata
come sangio per dostoevskij
nel libro delitto e castigo la mia retta
via che non sembra persa in tutte le
brutture del mondo crescendo mi sono
sempre resa conto che virginia mi ha
donato cioè mi ha sempre reso un po
diversa da quella che è stata la
crescita dei miei compagni è più che
altro perché magari dei comportamenti
per me giusti per me altruistici per me
conosciuti per loro sono ancora
inesistenti
questa differenza che hanno dato per me
è stata come una domanda esistenziale
esistenziale perché non riuscivo a
trovarle a trovare una risposta è
tutt'oggi ogni tanto aggiungo un
pezzettino la mia risposta
virginia mi porta molto spesso a fare
moltissime riflessioni come ad esempio
il perché la medicina non abbia ancora
trovato una soluzione è una causa certa
l'autismo ultimo comunque moltissimo la
professione medica perché la ritengo
veramente di fondamentale importanza per
la vita e senza di essa moltissime vite
andrebbero verso ogni giorno ma ritengo
anche che i medici delle volte siano
troppo bravi troppo che se nel loro
lavoro tanto da dimenticarsi del cuore e
dell'umanità
il mio spiegare l'autismo è facile per
scrivere delle cure lo stesso ma quando
si tratta di viverci tutti fanno a botte
e raramente si salva qualcuno un'altra
cosa su cui spesso ho riflettuto il
concetto di normale è diverso credo che
siano concetti molto soggettivi e che
delle volte siano diciamo nascosti
dietro degli stereotipi che ormai
oggigiorno sono in ogni cosa
quindi spesso mi chiedono ma come si può
definire virginia diversa se è un parere
soggettivo
beh alla fine ha il mio sangue
il mio stesso viso il mio stesso cognome
e la mia stessa risata contagiosa
quindi non comprendo proprio il perché è
il mio diverso ha contribuito alla
crescita della mia persona e per questo
le sono davvero debitrice mi manca tutto
quello che la gente giudicano
male ma non mi priverei mai del mio
diverso
grazie
[Applauso]